brett anderson who loves to go fast
two and two record making his sixth
start so freeman is on base for marcel
ozuna he'll be ready to swing the bat
and ozuna was and shoots that in the
center field of base hit
so freeman stops at second anderson's
first inning woes continue
the braves have a threat with ozzy
albee's coming up first and second one
out for ozzy albies
that ball is hammered toward left and
deep it is off the wall
freddie around third is going to score
ozuna's on his way to third
and ozzy albies with a rope to left and
the braves do
get things off to a great first inning
start a walk
a single and a double it's one nothing
atlanta
second and third one out so now dansby
swanson shoots one to deep center
back goes bradley onto the warding track
and he'll make the catch
oh zuna will tag and score ozzy moves up
90 feet as well
dansby just missed a three-run homer but
he does
pick up a sac fly and the braves extend
the lead ian anderson takes the hill
with a two-run lead
which is always a good feeling for a
starting pitcher and he
walks nervaez with one out and avasajil
garcia is coming up
this one on the ground tricky hop dansby
handled it and a bad throw
he rushed it after that ball may have
hit the lip of the grass
it's been an adventure for dansby at
shortstop in the
first few innings of this series but a
heck of a play to stay with that ball
and get the leading runner for the
second out
so garcia will be off to the races three
balls two strikes with two out
there he goes the pitch is right down
the middle
strike three and vogel back and the
brewers are done
in the first two nothing atlanta ian
anderson off to a good start in
milwaukee
two out single and that'll get freddie
freeman at bat
as this one is launched to deep left
center field
that's an historic homer for freddie
freeman
number 250 it comes
in milwaukee some very select company
freddie freeman joins with this pitch
down and in 89 and he hit it the other
way
a country mile his 10th home run tyrone
taylor over four last night as ian
anderson lets her rip and that's hit
toward third nice pick by reilly what a
play
and freeman the scoop wow a hot smash to
third
and riley somehow corralled that and was
able to get up and get the ball to first
base
in time for the out jackie bradley jr
the hitter
and the change has swung through and
anderson has finished the first
and the second with strike three and
heredia is the batter
and this ball is tattooed into right
center field and deep that ball's got a
chance to go
it's off the wall however contreras on
his way to third
and he is going to be stopped
already with an opposite field double
and the braves have more two out magic
second and third and at the very least
they'll clear ian anderson here
two two pets got another strikeout that
ends the inning
freddie anderson puts up a zero a couple
of hits couple left on for atlanta
let's see what he does 3-2 colton wong
will take off there he goes the pitch is
bounced right back to the mound
and anderson's got it a bullet to first
retires the side another ground ball out
for ian anderson who's shutting out the
brewers through three
braves have had base runners in every
single inning versus brad anderson
this one's shot toward right garcia is
on the run that ball is high off the
wall
and ozuna is on his way to third freddie
has
or i should say ozzy albee's has another
double
it's another short start back-to-back
games the brewers cannot get a starter
through four innings
and a pitching change with runners at
second and third and two outs drew
rasmussen
on his way in ozuna runner at third
alby's at second with his second double
of the night
and rasmussen fires a swing adam as he
got him with a fastball
that's a big out garcia vogelback and
shawn you up for the brewers braves on
top four
nothing well he went high with 94 and
that's where they've gone all series to
get garcia
strikeout number three and one out in
the inning
and travis shaw is coming up strike
three at the bottom of the zone that's
the same pitch that got volga back
shaw barca at home playing by chris
close to getting tossed here there he
goes alex shaw wanted to get run out of
this game
he knows you only get so much
leash arguing balls and strikes
and out he goes taylor advances to
second bradley's retired one out it's
billy mckinney
another ground ball into the shift
dansby's got it and ian anderson works
around the leader off walk
he preserves a four nothing atlanta lead
in game two
four walks comes with one out garcia is
the hitter
on the ground riley's got it second for
one long throw to first
they got him a double play riley's
strong arm
got the double play started a terrific
turn for ozzy obese garcia and the
brewers are done
in the sixth and they still are without
a hit
and ozzy albies who's continuing his hot
streak at the plate
high drive into center field
jbj at the wall and he makes the catch
oh what a play jackie bradley jr
takes a home run away from ozzy albees
oh what a play by jbj he had it measured
the whole way
he perfectly timed his leap and took
away
and back out there for a seventh inning
of work
which will certainly be his last
vogelback starts
vogel back center field little flare
falling fast and it's down
no hitter is over the first of the night
for the brewers
just reach down poked into center and
the fans rise
to applaud daniel vogelback and his base
hit
pablo reyes batting for the first time
reyes
in the left did he get it ozuna's back
near the wall
and it's off the wall we'll go back to
third
it's a double back-to-back hits for the
brewers
so ian henderson will depart after six
plus in a four-run lead
they are loaded and the brewers bring
the tying run to the plate
and a fly ball left field ozone a long
way to go
he will run it down that's going to
bring one in
scoring his vogel back brewers are
finally on the board on a sacrifice fly
starting with william contreras
high fly ball center bradley going back
as far as he can go
leaping try can't get that one big
insurance run for william contreras his
third home run of the year the ball was
up out over the plate high
almost hit it one-handed and now will
smith and the braves run out of way
the pitch is skyed left side who wants
this
it's riley and ozuna marcel's got it
and the braves win game two 5-1 your
score
one of the most complete games partner
the braves have played all year